this
is a spooky song
about
a railroad ghost
scarce type
no this doesn't kind of sound like a
railroad
hello everyone
i hope you got stepped out by that
railroad right now oh that wasn't spooky
at all i didn't want to play that song i
wanted to play that song so i just uh
pretended that he just lied
maybe maybe you guys shouldn't
stereotype what a spooky song should
sound like yeah maybe that that's true
welcome back everyone to another episode
of the corridor cast we got five of us
here today wow
[Laughter]
i've got the ramen jacket on right now
you do dude wow it's actually the same
color as my cup it is intentional no no
official i hope not i hope that at least
gosh that's what it is
i'm like why does that jacket have such
a brown and an orange exact same as well
i feel like i can taste your jacket yeah
at some point someone's like marketing
colors brown and orange
that's just like the seven yeah yeah
yeah it's retro lots of browns so i
guess the reason why jake was playing a
spooky song at the very beginning of
this podcast was because nick and i just
got back from a video trip where we went
to a ghost town
on top of a mountain this guy named
brent underwood bought a ghost town a
couple years ago 400 acres it's an old
mining town a silver mine yes and we
have been wanting to do a collab with
this guy all year every every like month
or so nick and i would be like yo how
about that uh that ghost town you want
to hit him we go to this ghost town
ghost town ghost town yeah and we
finally kind of came up with the right
idea and so we hit him up he was down
and it worked out we went out there with
jan so the three of us jan and uh
another guy named chris and
it was a good time so we're going to
tell you some stories from our from our
trip ooh spooky ghost stories yeah do
you have any of those there there are a
couple ghost stories from the town
really yeah
although
i was expecting to get some haunting
action and honestly there was nothing
but good vibes up there
for real that was one halloween wasn't
it it was like the day before it's
halloween eve yeah yeah
of the year yeah wow the third spookiest
night of the year um and
wait the
i'd say that's pretty spooky
365 days yeah and that's like about one
percent awake
yeah yeah for sure and
so you know top one percent spook can
you paint the picture of what this town
looks like for my mind's eye oh my gosh
so i mean it starts you're driving up
it's up near death valley so we're
driving up from l.a it's like a four or
five hour drive sorry like what ten
thousand feet above death valley or
something yeah because death valley is
like below sea level yeah it's way below
the town is at 8 500 feet which is
i don't know almost two
kilometers uh straight up in the air and
and you see it off in the distance
technically because you're looking at a
mountain range i only happen to finally
pick out where the town was from a
distance because i was like
i don't know i knew where it'd be
and you get up to it so there's a little
town down at the bottom of the road
called keeler and then you go up this
dirt road all the way up it's about
seven miles to the
seven miles sideways
and like basically one mile straight up
yeah it starts at like 3 500 feet and
ends at 8 500 feet
and it's a winding road dirt road not
very well maintained and i first like
okay this isn't too bad oh we probably
could have driven up uh in a nicer car
than jan's truck
and then it quickly got to a point was
like oh no this is a little on the
sketch side this is
yeah
there's this one stretch where you had
to get some speed to get up this one
incline and to the left is a like a 100
200 foot like not quite cliff but one of
those very steep
slopes that if you go off you just don't
stop oh and that's uh so you have to get
speed to go up this last little incline
that immediately corkscrews around
like switchback and so if you go too
fast you go off the other side
oh my god it wasn't that bad i think i
might be making it seem a little bit
worse than it was because i just imagine
going up in a horse-drawn carriage
though yeah like the 1800s when this
thing was made yeah it's insane and he
recently so brent the guy who owns the
place he uh recently got a like a five
ton military truck and he's very worried
about the air brakes on it apparently
air brakes are kind of finicky so he's
always concerned when he's going
downhill that his brakes are gonna give
out and so he carries with him like a
motorcycle helmet in the event that it
something like that happens
what you put on the helmet before you
create yourself
not off i thought the air was holding
the brakes open and if the air fails
and clamps shut i mean maybe that's how
it's supposed to work but things break i
don't know
it was a concern of his and he knows way
more about it than i do so he's like
yeah in the event of uh the brakes dying
or whatever he thought at first that
he's supposed to like steer it into the
the rock wall oh yeah um and just to
kind of grind it to a halt but the
problem is that like that'll flip the
truck
that's what he was saying is like some
like truck experts are like oh yeah
don't do that uh basically all you can
do is just grab the helmet get it on as
quick as you can
and jump off
jump off that's why they sort of okay
they have those they have those runaway
truck lanes on
the highways you know where it'll go
down and
up into basically just like a gravel
catch yeah yeah i've seen that that's a
nightmare
that would be a nightmare experience
especially on that mountain because it
is just like straight down don't watch
those desert hills
so that's that's the road right and
we're driving jan's driving us up in his
truck and uh jan throws on like some
western soundtracks like a playlist of
western songs so it actually like
it it was putting us in the mood pretty
good like i was like dang man westerns
are cool
oh there are so many passes along that
road that straight up looked like they
were out of fury road like seriously
like there'd be like some highwaymen
lurking amongst the cliffs and tuscan
raiders up there
ready to just hijack us but uh no yeah
we made it up and uh
you know the first day was all about
kind of
just exploring we did some awesome
one-wheeling
there's i mean it's basically a city
meant for one wheels because it's all
dirt roads yeah so you know it was
almost too much you know like some of
those roads we went on were a little too
steep for the one wheel oh yeah and like
all the terrain the gravel is like a
bunch of like fist-sized like shale
rocks well you're saying something
interesting like most of the rock there
is like all uh like just disposed waste
from the mines so it's all loose like
nothing's like dirt
but even like all the little pebbles and
stuff like i've never seen a one wheel
bite into the into a road so much like
when you ride at griffith or whatever
it's like you know you'll get a little
bit of slippage but like it's pretty
packed but this is like
if you try to start on any incline your
wheel will just dig in like
this it was super bizarre it was almost
like sand hard packed sand it was closer
to sand than dirt it was all like it was
all like dirt and gravel but instead of
soil based dirt which has like moisture
content and kind of like packs it
together this is all just like
pulverized rock because it's all just
the rock that they dug out of the ground
and just like dumped outside the hole
and that just accumulated over the
course of
however long this mine was in service i
guess it started in mid mid 1500s or so
really hit his heyday mid to late 1800s
fifteen hundreds it did not start in the
[Music]
from i believe 1500s the
1870s until the 1930s and okay it passed
that's a pretty big mine then it was it
was it was the largest mine in
california for a long time
and a major source of silver for the san
francisco mint
um you know when they meant all the
coins out there
and uh yeah man there's a ton of
interesting stories we learned it was
it was at first so they they mined
galena orr which is like a composite of
it's mostly lead but there is silver in
it so you get like 98 percent lead from
it exactly um oh yeah tasted it he can
speak to that a little bit more what do
you think it's like
pre-coin juice you know before it's
minted into coins
this is like the raw gatorade powder you
know
but
so lead was pretty lucrative back then
because they were using lead for
everything you know like they were just
going ham on lead yeah so like they
could actually like make a good profit
from this mine because it was like okay
we can sell the lead and the silver it's
great and what was cool about the silver
silver is that like all the silver
they're selling they were the number one
source of silver for all of los angeles
so like banks hotels they were getting
all these like little silver furnishings
on their building all coming from this
mine
and then when it uh later on when uh
hollywood started becoming more of a
thing and making film stock all of the
silver from that mine was going to all
the film stock all the screens
yeah exactly silver screen yeah um yeah
and so it was kind of funny it's like
here in this western town they mine all
the silver to make the film stock so
that they can come back and film their
westerns
because right there in the uh in the
valley of lone pine the town of lone
pine like literally right next to that
town was one of the hottest western uh
filming locations there's this hilly
area that's right under these beautiful
uh southern sierra mountains with these
cool jagged peaks and like those are in
like almost every period western yeah
it's called they got a real vertically
integrated enterprise
so yeah man i mean the silver made its
rounds for sure um but then you know
eventually is like you know everyone
started getting wise to the the lead
poisoning that i think became a little
bit less lucrative and
uh apparently zinc was mined there
a lot of zinc was the next thing that
was
like the mind it went through all these
different phases and you know at its
height
i think i mean it was a full-on town
with like hundreds of people living
there you know they have 400 buildings
yeah like 400 buildings and and today
when you go up there there's a grouping
of like five buildings yeah and then
most of the surviving buildings there's
one that's the general store that's the
original general store
where uh you know everyone would buy
their goods and there was also a butcher
in the back room and now that's the
museum
which is
it's really more of just like throw your
artifacts here you know like chuck
around there right there's no
recreational museum exactly and it will
be someday i'm sure it'll it'll have a
properly organized collection but now
it's just like heaven you're just like
whoa look at all this cool stuff right
it's so weird to like just like randomly
look at a thing on a table and be like
you pick it up and you're like this is
150 years old whoa
like what kind of stuff was was in there
oh dude they pull out everything yeah
like everything from like pepsi cans to
like pickaxes and
dynamite boxes uh levi's are the the
valuable one like hundred-year-old
levi's are worth like oh yeah 100 grand
i think that's why i think that's like
you can you can see the sparkle in
brent's eye when he talks about the
levi's you know because because
literally yeah they are if you think
about it levi's were created for the
mining industry in california yeah you
know in the mid eight or mid you find a
pre-red tab pair of levi's that's in
good condition wearable conditions
yeah
like yeah
because levi's will purchase them
directly from you so a lot of these
minor like mine explorers that's what
they're looking for you know tools
rusted metal old wood the levi's there's
a lot of that stuff because if you think
about it these mines they weren't some
heritage site or or museum place it was
just like it was just the job and some
guy just like dropped his canteen one
like whatever
he didn't realize that was the last day
he was gonna be down in that mine and
now a hundred years later that canteen
is still there it's all rusted up now
uh but like
everything you find there is just like
random stuff just left behind yeah and
that's partly what i like is like you
have that character like this was an
actual legitimately used we found that
pickaxe that had it had been used so
much his handprint had started getting
embedded into the wood wow
um yeah there's a lot of really cool
like personal items like that and just
like things that make you really that's
why i love history too and like you know
holding artifacts going to museums
you're like damn they're just normal
people yeah although they had the
crappiest job in the world and the mine
system there apparently there's like 30
miles worth of tunnels geez
under that mountain there and there's
nine levels each separated by a hundred
feet so the bottom level is 900 feet
underground and you take an uh this it's
called the hoist yeah and it's basically
an elevator just dangling from a rope uh
steam powered
and a cable but it's a cable it's a it's
like a you know 100 year old cable
that's been pulled you know
there's a little bit of a scariness to
it
what not and it takes like an hour to
get to the bottom so you're just
standing on this like platform with no
rails or anything around you and you're
just seeing like the the shaft go up
around you
yeah for an hour you can't sit down yeah
i mean there's like i mean you could
probably put a little chair there and
have enough room to sit but if there's
three guys standing up so like you could
sit down yeah yeah did you do it no no
no okay it's like it requires like a
letter
it's too much of a liability yeah yeah
no kidding yeah i don't know if i'd do
it yeah i don't know if i'd really want
to do it yeah i would want
speaking of which why were we there nick
um well
guys christmas has come early to the
corridor cast courtesy of today's
sponsor manscape now if you can't see
what's in front of me well they've got a
whole selection of products just in time
for the holiday season including a brand
new body wash and two-in-one shampoo and
conditioner as well as the performance
package 4.0 oh now a bunch of great
products in here and i got to tell you
all about them because if you use the
code cord or cast at checkout you can
get 20 off any of these products plus
free shipping 20 off plus free shipping
so first and foremost they're going
beyond the groin this holiday with a
ultra premium body wash courtesy of
manscape this is a brand new product
from them they also hey they said why
not just do body wash let's do a two in
one shampoo and conditioner so not only
are you going to clean your scalp you're
also going to moisturize it because if
you don't know that's what conditioner
is for took me years to learn that but
that's not all they also have the weed
whacker which is always available for
your nose your ears and wherever else
you need a weed whacker and they've got
this amazing package the performance
package
4.0 this comes with their signature
lawnmower trimmer with the lockable
travel switch the
super intense led light so you can see
in those hard to reach places and with
that patented skin safe technology which
is going to make sure that you don't
suffer from any slices while you're
doing your business the performance
package 4.0 also includes the crop
preserver and crop reviver which is the
anti-chafing deodorant moisturizer and
toner which is going to keep you feeling
and smelling fresh all day long in
addition this hygiene bundle comes with
a pair of manscaped anti-shaving boxers
none of these boxes will keep you
feeling comfortable all day and they're
really the perfect thing to go with this
perfect package for your perfect package
really so if you guys are interested in
getting your hands on any of these goods
head on over to manscapes.com and use
the code corridor cast at checkout for
20 off plus free shipping 20 off
free shipping get it for whoever you
need it's a great gift for a company
that specializes in these products just
for you huge thanks to them for
sponsoring the podcast they make a great
trimmer and a bunch of other great stuff
too so anyways thanks to them and now
back to the episode i mean i mean i
think for some ren and i love his
channel yeah we've been watching the
channel for a while it's called ghost
town living yeah and and his whole thing
is like he wants to preserve the town he
wants to like you know rebuild it make
it into a tourist attraction
um
and so
we thought that a good way to help him
in those efforts would be
to
like photo scan the town and kind of
capture it in 3d as it is because
last year i think it was last year now
gosh um the
the crown jewel of the town that was
still there called the american hotel
um
burnt down
yeah randomly no one knows why literally
the crown jewel of the whole like it was
in the perfect spot for like the best
photos
and all that stuff this was an original
from the 1800s this was the building you
know this was the hotel where everyone
would gamble you know who knows how many
murders happened there how many ghosts
were there brent said that they were
having a uh
there was a murder a week yeah there was
a murder per week in its heyday not a
death a murder yeah
so more deaths
it's just primed for for spirits up
there yeah all the ghosts burned and
not to mention so i think we should get
into some of the the scary stories he
told but he told one story that was
actually like legit he told a couple
that i found very interesting that speak
to a couple different things about these
ghost hunting shows but
the reason we went up there though was
the 3d scan this place and you know god
forbid another one of these old wooden
buildings burnt down he would have a 3d
construction and record of what this
looked like so if you wanted to rebuild
or you know show people that's there
forever now so
yeah that's what we did we spent a whole
day doing that yeah and so yeah we uh we
did the video with polycam so we're
doing all like the 3d scanning and
whatnot using uh polycam which is just
like a 3d scanning app on my phone just
that's
just a 3d it's yeah you know it's just a
it's like a super super futuristic
advanced app on your phone that creates
magic uh so cool
i've become re-obsessed with it every
now and then like i become obsessed with
it but the photo mode on it is it gets
like the craziest uh high quality
captures so i've been i've been obsessed
with the app lately but
yeah so it's we're actually doing this
video in partnership with polycam and so
the ceo of polycam
came out with us and so it's kind of
nuts it's just like us three you me and
jan and the ceo of polycam just driving
out in this pickup truck and he was
very uh well really nice guy first of
all and also really helpful to have the
ceo of the app that we're using this
game yeah to be there and he was just
like in scanning heaven because he loved
it this guy loves scandinavia
i really hope so which you would hope
exactly you wouldn't want someone who's
like no i don't i don't [ __ ] with that
like don't scam he also just happens to
have like a phd in like theoretical
particle physics yeah he dropped that
casually on us one night when we were
sitting around the the table he was just
like oh yeah he's like yeah so i got my
phd and then
decided that i didn't want to go become
a professor so i got into 3d scanning
[Laughter]
wow so he's a very intelligent dude and
also really uh really nice yeah uh but
yeah no it was really nice about that is
that he was able to basically unlock a
lot of the back end stuff
from from polycam to allow us to do like
high level skating like basically when
you have a 3d scan you're limited to 250
photos within the app but because he had
the magic ceo key to the app
he could have unlimited so
we're taking thousands of photos well uh
to of like each individual building of
the entire valley inside the buildings
and that's that was probably the best
part honestly it was at the end of the
day once like the sun went down we
maximized our light it's like all right
now it's time to go inside the mine into
the tunnel
and yeah we used uh the app to scan the
entire length of this one mine it was
off to the side it wasn't like one of
the ones super far underground was easy
to get to but it was like
way longer than i
expected it to be i thought it was gonna
be like this little thing i was like uh
i was kind of hoping to do a little bit
more mine exploring but this was like
plenty oh no you're you're under the
mountain and it kind of hits you too
you're like oh i'm really i'm really
under a lot of rock right now yeah
especially any time you hit your head on
the roof which happened a lot or like
uh you know maybe we don't need helmets
we brought our one-wheeling helmets and
brent was like no you wanna you want a
helmet and we're like okay fine like i
want to look dumb or whatever yeah we
hit our heads so many times yeah and
like oh my god dude like so i had my one
wheel helmet on and i hit my head
i don't even know how many dozens of
times just accidentally a few times
pretty hard i hit him on the wall like
there'll be little rocks like sticking
out and you hit it the worst part though
was when i would hit
like the roof or something and it would
all just rain debris down my back and
down my shoulders
because it wasn't solid rock it was very
loosely packed like shale almost and
you know there's different ores that are
much more solid there's different veins
of like you know you get the iron vein
or whatever and like it's really cool to
see actually like the different layers
and pockets but
it's loose like
so when you're healthy
it starts like crumbling like is this it
yeah
yeah those are the moments where you're
like oh boy i mean they had uh i don't
know how long ago it was but the the big
cave in that they had uh it was on the
200 level so it was around the same
level that we were on actually if we
kept going it would have we had to go
down this hole but it would have met up
with the 200 level but it would have
been closed off because they had a cave
in and over 30 miners died so so 30
souls were trapped this is one of the
ghost stories
we're trapped in this mine and a lot of
it
is behind that that wall basically of
rock right 30 souls
and
this is just like no one's gotten in
there because it's basically impossible
to go in so there are probably 30 dudes
just like with levi's jeans
except so so the thing is
the thing is
the creepy part
a ghost show came
and
one of those ghost hunters shows right
they came and they did this whole
investigation brent was telling us about
this yes
brent gave us the the inside scoop and
they were doing the recordings right
and they record you know how they do and
then they play backwards or whatever and
they like analyze it and they hear and
they heard a voice
and it literally sounded just like a guy
going i'm going to work
i'm going to work going to work going to
work and like they're like damn dude and
they made a huge deal of it it was super
scary with the music and stuff in the
show and then brent he's like he just
kind of laughs well he was amused he's
like no they they did their research
yeah yeah they really did their research
except for they didn't
because
all the miners were chinese miners
so there's no way they would have been
saying that so yeah those shows are
[ __ ] just like a girl from their
american accent no yeah they're like
going to work
but that also so
there also
i learned was a huge population like
there was in the 1800s
of chinese miners that were horribly
treated they were exploited they were
giving the worst jobs and you know often
they were the ones that are put in the
mines that are most likely to collapse
so
there's actually another town on the
other side of the mountain because they
were also segregated from the white
miners um so they had to build their own
town on the other side of the mountain
did they build the town in fort minor in
fort minor yeah
sorry that was bad well it was more like
a fort because they actually constructed
all their buildings out of stone so
there's actually a bunch of stone
foundations over there that have barely
been explored or you know um shown on
the channel that's the just the chinese
like settlement which is really cool and
he's found all these cool like old
chinese coins and like you know chinese
papers and stuff over there
so it's pretty it's pretty interesting
and really messed up
but it's interesting here hearing you
guys talk about uh
like mining culture
because
that's i i don't know if you guys know
this mike a lot of people on my
grandparents side including a few of my
grandparents and they were all iron ore
miners
and they came over in like the basically
during and after world war one
[Music]
to mine iron ore well obviously in
northern minnesota yeah and
so a lot of the stuff that you guys are
it's it's just bringing back like
a lot of information that i've i've i've
learned over the years about like the
the like the substance of the the mines
and like the the shafts the hoists
lower you down and how they'd separate
them by like a hundred feet and dude
jake you'd get a kick out of all the
like huge machinery and these hoists man
they're it's just like this huge
steampunk contraptions there was a huge
steam furnace that's like as big as this
room and they just keep they just chuck
[ __ ] in there burn it all day long oh
wow
but they turned it all on yeah there
used to be a forest on the mountain not
anymore
um there's a mine in northern minnesota
called the sudan underground mine that's
let's see it's known as minnesota's
oldest deepest and richest iron mine i
went in at one time it has this giant
they have it renovated and they have one
of those giant
elevators wow and it's just and they
take you down like for five minutes and
they're like yeah and if you want to you
can go down for another two hours
yeah it's or whatever it is it's
freezing down there too it's yeah oh god
it's cold
oh yeah it's it's really cold which
makes it even more spooky honestly and
well except i got the opposite of cold i
got very very hot yeah well you were so
rea
was freaking crawling around like a
gremlin with his 3d scanning device
like
it's not it's not comfortable to walk
because you're you can't stand up like
the the roof is like right at forehead
level
are you like six one
six two yeah yeah tall but anyway so
yeah i mean somewhere between six one
and six two and with a helmet on you
know a little bit taller but like
there were some sections where you could
stand up straight but most of the tunnel
is like right at that height where you
can't quite stand straight and so you
like you try to find like the most
comfortable positions like bending down
a little bit or like leaning over and we
built this like rig that basically was a
bunch of cheese plate stuff for camera
for the black magic camera and we
attached a whole bunch of our lights to
it like little handheld lights you see
on top of the camera and in the vlogs
like six or seven of them and then with
the little
phone mount in the middle so that
everywhere i was scanning it was being
perfectly illuminated by the lights so
it's this big rig and i'm just trying to
get all of the
the
you know just swinging it around in a
corkscrew but slowly you know forward
and backwards and whatnot and so it was
a lot of just me leaning over with all
the strain going into my lower back like
i tried doing it like crouched more my
thighs rather than my back but like i
couldn't move that way and
so after it took an hour to scan this
tunnel it was so long it was just like
just doing this just inch by inch
so you have to hope the app didn't like
lose tracking or something
uh the app did crash on me uh twice
halfway through the scan but they
anticipated something like that
happening apparently it's kind of on
apple's side there's like this weird
glitch that sometimes happens so the
longer you go scanning the better chance
you have of that dice rolling a one uh
but they built in a safety thing
basically if it does crash what you
scanned is backed up like instantly and
so you're able to reopen it and then and
then process it but i had to do the
whole the scan of the whole mine in like
four separate scans and each one was
huge
did uh
the guy that owned it uh brett brent
brent
yeah did he did he have any birds
for the actual mines no okay so we
talked to him about that too like the
canary in a coal mine but this isn't a
coal mine so there's no need for any
birds because there's not any gases
being emitted down there yeah
so that was one of the first questions
jan actually asked yeah well they
so my grandfather used to catch um like
saw they weren't canaries but they were
basically they're little songbirds i
forget what kind they were he used to
catch him with this little like
basically with like a fishing lot uh
like a fishing pole with a with like a
little noose on it
and he'd catch them and then they'd sell
them to the miners and then the miners
would put them in there wow um i don't
know if they still did that for silver
or whatever but yeah that's the way to
go with that ass
yeah i'm free i'm flying in the sky oh
now i'm in a tunnel 500 feet under the
work
i know that's not where bird wants to be
although there were bats we saw some
spooky bags oh dude yeah there was a bat
in there i looked up and there was a bat
right next to my face and then a tiny
little thing we went ahead of ren ren
was still scanning and we were all
heading back to the entrance and like i
feel this like this
hit my ear and this little bat flitters
by i'm like man that was a halloween eve
miracle
that's right i thought the bat was dead
because it was just like we were right
up next to it like within inches of it
brent even had his camera and almost
touched it he got that close and i was
like is it dead he's like no he's like
he's just he's being a bat he's just
being a bat i mean you won't see those
under in the union mine which is you
know you have to go vertically down but
still this is one that you can access
from tell me about the hole
oh god the the holes hold there's this
one hole in this mine that we went to uh
you go back and you go into it and
there's obviously holes going down and
up and every which direction but there's
this one hole that was
the spookiest hole i've ever seen it was
such a spooky hole and
uh it was perfectly perfectly circular
maybe about four
five-ish feet across in diameter like a
meter meter and a half
uh perfectly circular and then straight
down like a like someone just bored out
a hole straight down to the point that
you couldn't see anymore it was just
like darkness wow and there was a bit of
a walkway around it like you could just
kind of like skirt around it to keep
walking down the rest of the tunnel and
i was scanning i got to there i was like
i'm not going past this because also
standing down into it was like this that
gravelly loose dusty stuff
and it was like
rolling down into the hole just the same
my foot was on top of it i'm like i'm
not going across that and then we
finally like get out of the mine and
chris is showing me the scan and he's
clearly showing me the scan that
encapsulates the hole the little nook
behind the hole and the tunnel past the
hole
and i'm like
you went
you went past that he's like yeah man
that hole was scary
so you walked around that loose
well all for the scan dude all over the
place
that's that's how much this guy likes
scanning he's a scan man for sure he's a
scam i'm a scam
yeah dude we actually did a lot of uh
like brainstorming about how we'd how
we'd be able to scan the the union mine
shaft like that goes 900 feet down we
have a lot of ideas like i think we need
to try to follow up on this with
breakfast if we do a part two that's
what we'd have he does a ton of videos
and they're awesome videos where he
explores this union mind and like he's
constantly
he said he's explored probably 20 of the
whole thing and that's after over two
years nineteen months of doing a lot of
exploration yeah now it's a bit of a
production to actually get the uh the
hoist operating because he has to have a
guy there
full time
operating the hoist yeah well and you
have to be basically ready to like take
it back up if something happens or the
radio only transmits on certain levels
like it's kind of weird it's like you
said like from the 300 to something like
there's no radio service but once you
get down to 700 feet on the seven level
there is service so like you get radio
service from the other side of the earth
it's it's so sketch there's like i was
watching this video last night actually
it was put out a couple months ago it's
he finally went down to the 900 level
which is the lowest level the hoist down
there is a 1 100 level where you have to
take a tunnel and then descend manually
down the tunnel there's an old ladder
there but the hoist only goes to 900. he
finally went down there
and the the hoist had not gone down
there for 100 years wow so like they had
to like there was one point where the
the voice gets stuck because there's
wooden guide beams and they've bent and
bowed from years of pressure
so they had like they got stuck and they
had to file the beam away so that the
hoist could keep going down yeah they
actually bring with them like a sawzall
type thing just like like a little saw
that goes back and forth and they they
they have to belt in and go hang
underneath the hoist oh
like straight out of like freaking
mission impossible you get out of the
elevator you climb underneath it and
then they have the saw they're literally
dangling from it and they're sawing into
the wood beam that is holding the hoist
like not in place but at least guided
and if the there is also a safety
mechanism if the the cable was to snap
or something uh
there's these clamps that are supposed
to clamp onto those wood guide uh
yeah they kind of like dig in sure
and but
exactly
like yeah but if that happens they'd
probably just shred it and you just
plumb it the rest of the way so
hopefully yeah you'd be able to be a
gunner
okay so this this this sedan mine that i
was telling you guys about in minnesota
is a sedan
that's where they get the cars it's
called it's called the sedan mine it's
2
341 feet it goes 2 341 feet
713 meters jeez nice man so absurd
i can't believe yeah i didn't like
you're reaching depths where like the
air pressure is noticeably
thicker yeah
i mean even i was feeling like
lightheaded from walking around in that
mountain like up that high because we
were up high alone the other thing is
that the
the air is so thin that you you you're
just doing a normal thing like walking
around you're like why am i out of
breath
why am i cramping up this is weird oh
yeah because the air is really thin up
here yeah the air's thin the sun hits
you hard and 8 500 feet very high yeah
yeah man so we went up to the peak on
our one wheels
uh which wasn't the easiest thing to do
uh and that was another 1500 feet so i
we think we're at around 10 000 feet up
at the very top
wow but the ride down was right now it's
amazing that's like um so when when they
do uh when when tr when track athletes
do like altitude training
they'll go up to somewhere usually
between like 5 000 and like 7 000 feet
but then there's some legendary guys who
used to who used to go up to like
10 000 feet for like a few months at a
time
to train and then come back down
i did i did it when i was in college and
i went we went up to albuquerque which
is
up near the mountain base of
albuquerque's like 6 000 feet
and when we came back down i remember
the first year that i did it
when we came back down it it felt like
you had gained a superpower when you got
back down to sea level it was like the
ability to breathe easier
was so intensified
it i can't even explain it it was like a
truck because like your body actually
like learns how to just absorb more
oxygen i believe you actually end up
with more red blood cells in your body
yeah that's what you do yeah yeah yeah i
don't yeah i don't know there's an also
very dangerous way to do that called
blood doping where you take your blood
out of your body put it in a freezer and
then put your own blood back in your
body later
and that's a great way to get a blood
clot and die yeah and people have died
from it it's also undetectable isn't it
as far as like yes well because it's
your own blood
at the training house we used to stay at
in albuquerque there was this russian
racer who used to stay there and like
one day my buddy chalmers opened the
freezer
and he's like what is and she had her
blood back there
and then uh like a year later she got
caught uh blood
dude there was this box there in the
warehouse that said human blood handle
with care
and i got them a perfect photo of of jan
and nick opening the thing and just like
this look of amazement on their eyes as
they like look into the box i mean i've
never seen a human blood box and this
was labeled officially and we opened it
up and it's actually an insulated box
where you would have ground ice this was
probably from the 30s when because like
a lot of the stuff that's there and the
current layout of his mind is all from
the third time yeah of course like
there's no blood in there but it's for
blood that's for if someone had an
injury you'd have blood on on deck i
guess so but the box is still on deck
i got good blood here
and there's all these like old like
instructions for how to you know you've
got to keep the blood within this
temperature and stuff so it's yeah it's
a blood donor box but yeah so we brought
jan with us because you know jan's all
about them ghosts and ghost stories
loved all this oh
we have never met brent before and jan
knew even less about brent than we did
uh
and so jan was a little skeptical of
what kind of guy goes out and just lives
in a ghost town full time you got to be
a certain kind of person like messed up
sociopath kind of to do that and then he
meets brent and we hang out for like
literally less than a day and at the end
of that day uh jan was like
he's incredibly cool
he's like i was wrong about everything
yeah jane was like trust me man it's
gonna be we're gonna get there and
tonight like once everyone's gone we're
sitting around the campfire he's gonna
start talking about the flat earth and
all this stuff he's like he's gonna be
like a q and on guy and he's like
couldn't have been farther from the
truth brent was like such a cool normal
guy like he was very charismatic and
just like fun to hang out with uh yeah
but dan's just going up there every
weekend after this yeah well jan really
wanted to go spelunking into some of
those mines he brought like his climbing
gear but we're like dan no we gotta do
scanning i think dan might move but so
jan one thing even after establishing
this that jan was still skeptical on was
can he tell a good ghost story
and
i'm not gonna be able to do it justice
so i'm not gonna retell this ghost story
uh apparently brent hasn't even told
anyone else this story like publicly on
his youtube channel uh but
it was a legitimately kind of creepy it
had to do with like there's a person he
saw in in the bunk house
and
he thought they'd let like they'd left
the lights on and and brent's also
establishing like i'm a very logical
person i don't believe in ghosts i don't
believe in any of this stuff and then he
goes on to basically describe this ghost
story that made all of our hair just
kind of like stand up yeah like he goes
into the house
after being like i thought i'd turn the
lights off and the lights are on and he
goes like deeper and deeper down the
hallway when there's these rooms from
this old bunk house and
he was just describing how like he was
having this overwhelming feeling of i
should not be here i need to get out and
it got so overwhelming that by the time
he got to the last room he couldn't look
into it and had to just turn around and
run out
of speed and he says he never goes back
in there at night oh man
and like so then he ended up like doing
this whole uh yeah
he specifically told us
can we take a quick tangent on that on
that real quick have you guys ever had
anybody that you know personally or
yourselves have any ghost like
encounters yes i have friends that have
slash cousins that have said they've
encountered ghosts but yeah
i personally have never encountered a
ghost i never personally have i have a
friend whoever has a ghost story i just
feel like most ghost stories are just
people misinterpreting yeah i agree the
closest thing i've ever experienced is
the freaking footsteps that were above
my ceiling that one time that freaked me
out and i still don't have an
explanation but i'm not gonna say it's a
ghost
i don't know what it was we tried to get
to the bottom of that one we made a
whole video about it it was weird it was
very weird but also
i'm sure there's an explanation
i hope
it's it's probably a ghost that's
probably the exhibition
it's probably a ghost oh have you jake
well my brother my brother stayed in a
house in college that was definitely
haunted by a little girl ghost see it's
always a little girl though like that's
what makes me skeptical it's always like
it would play games with them it would
like draw on the mirror
it would uh it would throw the cds off
of the uh off the top of the uh
refrigerator in this huge kitchen
um and then a couple of them saw it
a few times
and um it would do stuff like that
and then uh one of my old girlfriends uh
her cousin's house that they grew up in
was like
everybody in their family had seen this
very particular ghost that would appear
at this very particular time at this
very particular place in the house
and uh
and even yeah so
i don't want to sound like a crazy
person but
there's definitely something going on i
like that we're doing the spooky ghost
story podcast after halloween i mean
yeah and maybe someone will watch it
it's currently november 3rd so i want to
watch this in october 2022. yeah
yeah ready for spooks save this one for
later yeah put this on your watch later
oh another cool thing i'm pretty sure
jan is the very first person ever to
ride a one wheel through an actual
silver mine oh yeah or mine of anything
i got it on video we got to put that in
in the crew yeah
oh yeah
i think i was the first one to do a
revert on a one wheel in a mine
oh i was the first person to film a guy
1 million
yeah no there are a lot of records i
think we're the first person we're the
first people i think to one wheel down
from there yeah one wheeled we one
wheeled all almost 5000 feet down the
mountain and it took us over an hour
um it was a major journey
we thought it was going to be easy but
like those roads are that was a
crazy day oh my god did i show you
nick's fall off his onewheel yeah yeah
it was great it was i i just happened to
have my phone required i was doing like
one of those like selfie videos where i
you can see the riders in the background
and i've been rolling for about four
seconds
when you hit a rock and your board
folded sideways but then recovered
and you're starting to veer off to the
side you're going to get your balance
back but you immediately hit a second
bigger rock on the other side of the
wheel that yeah on the other side of the
wheel that caused your board to fold the
other direction and it is it's the most
amazing video i've ever taken because
you clearly are going this way and your
foot catches the the fender the magnetic
fender so it looks like your one wheel
just explodes
you go flying off the side and then you
executed like the most perfect roll and
we're totally fine and i was like yeah i
i got good training from brett the sun
on how to fall and roll
so you're gonna have to show me that one
i feel like we should we should go stay
up there i i mean honestly it was one of
those things it was like we have to film
something here we have to come back and
film a film or a short film or whatever
like who knows uh he's super down to
have us back uh it'd be really cool
there were a lot more people up there
than i expected really um there was like
a whole family like two different
families of volunteers that were staying
the night there a lot of randos show up
during the day
it's like it's like how our studio used
to be but like way more because like
his channel has found really good
success i think he's at 1.5 million
subscribers now but oh 1.3 1.3
um but like a lot of people
just show up it's a public road so you
can't get it off
right and he doesn't try to
does it go through his town the road
goes through the town it goes up to the
uh the like there's some edge of the
death valley yeah yeah there's some
towers in there so they have to be
experienced so he can't shut it off but
he does he owns the
everything around exactly so he could
put a gate to the the minor roads that
go into the actual town grid
but yeah and he kind of does have that
he's got like a chained uh thing that he
can take down i mean if you're walking
you just walk around but right now i
mean it's just kind of like anyone can
show up and like you know there were a
couple guys for instance that came and
they're like hey brent like and they're
like these like these old uh one of them
was like a gold miner one was an
excavator guy like who like you know was
a heavy machinery pilot and they're like
hey brent like we love your stuff and
you know everyone wants face time with
them and like you know to get shown
around so i'm sure that's very taxing on
him as well just like he has to play
host as well as like you know make
videos and work his day job yeah he
actually i didn't realize that he
actually has like a job he runs an
ecommerce website
yeah yeah wait so he wants a what an
e-commerce website
marketing in books and stuff like that
i mean he's got his own ebay page almost
almost
so so
i'm sure you can just go on his youtube
channel if you want the details but like
how does he actually live there like
survive there in a town that doesn't
have like running water well first off
it does have electricity it does yes i
was i i
was surprised i didn't realize that for
the longest time because when we were
talking about this earlier this year i
was like oh we're gonna have to bring up
a bunch of solar panels that we can
charge some batteries so that we can
charge our own wheels and maybe some
cameras but uh
yeah they have like most of the
buildings that have power or like the
main buildings like there's a couple
buildings there that have power uh where
we say it had power and he just got
internet installed the week before we
showed up it was this whole crazy thing
they have to like basically beam it from
lone pine to healer up to this point on
the mountain up to another point on the
mountain and then to the town it's all
like line of sight laser internet it's
another one of those things though where
it's like a fan reached out to him was
like hey like i do networking like i can
get you internet and he's like all right
and so that's what happened and like
that happened
with the internet company to get it all
yeah that's approved these two like
these two guys who came up and they're
you know they were like yeah we want to
we want to camp on the other side of the
mountain
and there was this exchange that went on
where it was like uh scotty who's
brent's like uh like he he's one
employee he's kind of like the park
ranger of the whole place
he does a lot of like he talks with a
lot of volunteers and stuff they have
like a whole bunch of brands
are these guys able to camp on the
mountain and branches like well like
they're just here to camp that's it and
he's like well what can they do you know
and scott is like well one of them has
heavy machinery experience and he's like
well can they clear that site up there
yeah so like everyone and that's what
they ended up doing that whole day these
guys were up in the excavator clearing
the site of this old cabin that used to
be there because we were there trying to
start our day when those two guys showed
up and this is like these old dudes with
big white beards kind of just show up
and like oh so like and like there was
another guy on the friday we were there
who was like kind of uh he was
rebuilding a cabin from the old lumber
that because basically there used to be
like what 400 structures on this place
and it was it was probably something out
of like a fallout or like a far cry game
where like you're in like this little
shanty town up there because this whole
valley had buildings like on multiple
levels going around the whole thing it
must have been a site when it was all
lit up at night with oil lamps and stuff
but now
it's just you can see kind of where the
foundations are and there's piles of old
lumber and
rubble but most of it's been buried so
brent is you know ever on the quest to
excavate and like rebuild a lot of these
cabin sites using the original timber
that was there
using the original like you know rocks
and stuff from the site so it's really
cool man is this it's very funny like
these two random guys show up and
they're like oh we want to camp on the
other side he's like and he's like uh
we'll like excavate stuff for you he's
like okay have fun yeah it's like you
mean like if you show up there and you
want to work and do something then
you're welcome you know yeah
it was like this this kid who drove down
in a white sedan from oregon one day
to hunter street oh no and showed up and
was like hey
i know how to shoot videos and do stuff
my name's wren
he's like i was thinking i just make a
baby
yeah i mean you're describing the time i
like i move down here
yeah it's like well we need a guy who
has fire hands experience
like i know
i know how to do that i would not say
that those two things are the same at
all
but i appreciate the throwback reference
yeah i'm just going old-school yeah man
jake i mean if we wanted to go up there
and help build the hotel or whatever
he's totally down you know that would be
so
cool long as you can open carry
like a true western town on his property
then we're good to go i i don't
i didn't hear anything about that but i
don't think anyone i mean if it's his
property he should be able to
there's like
eagles and [ __ ] that attack so you might
want to have a gun
yeah they do have a lot of science
saying that if you're trespassing
they'll shoot you yeah there you go see
so we can be those guys we can be the
park enforcers
jake that can be your job
so most of this podcast has been kind of
dominated by this ghost town talk it's
so cool
this podcast is pure ghost yeah
i have so many questions
there's a big sierra the bottom of the
sierras on the other side this mountain
huge range right here and it's a huge
dry lake bed or so we thought
a hundred years ago it was a huge lake
and it had to have been gorgeous he said
it was like 70 feet at his house
gorgeous blue deep blue lake like crater
lake blue it was so big it was like
the miners
literally at the bottom of the hill in
keeler there was a port and that's how
they they'd have to transport all the
ore from the mayan across these barges
to the other side of the lake and then
the road to la was about a two-week road
you know to get to la to take the ore
down there but
this was like a major
port like in lake and like a place where
it was
yeah and then like a hundred years ago
or so i forget the specific details but
various uh
damning of rivers and stuff if you've
seen the movie chinatown basically
there's all this stuff looking at uh
allocation of water to la basically
through all these sketchy sketchy deals
inside deals and this lake in particular
was one of the ones that was totally
drained yeah
and all the water was diverted down so
now
any rain water from the sierras gets
immediately diverted down to us
um
and
he was saying something about the
mentality of the towns people down there
how
they're actually kind of happy about it
like you'd think that
you know so brent's gone and talked to
like the population of keeler which is
the town is about 30 people and then you
have lone pine which is a little bit
more which is like half an hour away
yeah but they're all like you know
um
people either go to the water or
the water goes or
they either take the water to the people
or the people will come to the water
and they don't want like you know if the
water had stayed at the lake it would be
a very different place so this would be
one of the biggest lakes
in socal it would probably be probably
one of the biggest tourist attractions
exactly exactly so looking at some of
the
footage of the town and i can see in
that valley how there's a dry lake there
yeah yeah so
the crazy thing about that lake though
is that once it dried up it started
getting very dusty
and you had all of this dust getting up
and going states wide we're talking
huge dust storms the size of literal
states yeah in the dust bowl you might
know a little bit about it was getting
partly right into la too yeah and so
they realized that they have to kind of
keep this whole valley wet which is a
problem because they drained all the
water out of it and so
he was telling us about this apparently
there's a government project now that is
entirely about wetting down the whole
dry lake bed
and you're like okay sure just you know
but it it it gets very intense they have
basically every square inch of that
entire valley is monitored they have
thousands and thousands of sprinklers uh
ready to go it's all computer monitored
they have airplanes going over twice a
week to figure out which areas are dusty
because you have to keep it at right the
right level of of
moisture content he was saying it's like
it's it's a billion dollars a year
and we don't have we've never heard of
this we've never heard no one's
there's a whole government department of
dust management
of government expenditures yeah when
they ask you if they can have some more
just remember that well okay i mean keep
your political
it seems ridiculous but that's the
amount of money it requires to keep that
entire valley under management and if
they and we never hear about it because
it's not a problem if they were not
doing that it would become a problem
very quickly apparently the whole place
would get dusty and then it would just
be nothing but haze for the entire
southern half of california that's crazy
very very unhealthy to breathe because
it's not just dust it's all like that
freaking metallic dust to get out of the
mountain there because it's a lot of
just like mined runoff oh yeah there's a
lot of like i forgot what the actual
chemical
yeah yeah just a little cyanide cyanide
yeah i know i don't know how to yeah
because like i saw one photo that had
the entire like from the top of the
mountain that had the entire lake filled
and it was just a perfect reflection of
the mountain range on the other side of
the lake wow it was the most incredible
photo because that that small range of
mountains right there the bottom of the
sierras is already just incredible it's
amazing yeah it would have been this
would have been a major like resort town
now like you know where rich people
would have their boats and sure you know
there'd be spas and stuff so like the
townspeople are quite glad it's not that
i think they've kind of like accepted
this but
i mean sometimes old enough to remember
the lake but well yeah yeah but still
like i think i remember the lake i
remember the great lake
this is the most engineered piece of
land the most engineered piece of land
in the entire country that's crazy yeah
like by a huge margin apparently so
we're starting to like get to the end of
this podcast here so before we go
there's one last thing i kind of want to
talk about and it's the biggest reason
why i want to go back to saragordo which
is the name of this mining town
the onewheel gt was announced last week
and it is a more powerful onewheel we
have yet to know how it's going to ride
people are really worried about the
pushback on it it's like
limited to 20 miles an hour but it's a
self-balancing thing you can push past
it so one of the things they have is
it'll like lean back on you anyway but
outside of that it has a lot more torque
a lot more power so i think it can
actually go up some of those roads that
the xr and i've got a
pretty over modified xr one wheel uh you
know 25 30 miles of range the off-road
or the
aftermarket uh
bumpers and rails and tire it could it
handle that stuff fairly well but there
are a few points was a little too steep
and i really want to get the one wheel
gt up there and test it on that on those
hills if they can do those hills
it's a good one
so that's the reason i'm very excited
i'm very excited to get the onewheel gt
and i'm very excited to
eventually go back because if i do i'm
definitely bringing it with me i almost
bought one
then i like i realized look i already
got the treaded tire all right we have
the concave foot pads yep i already have
the extended battery the power would be
wonderful if the power is better i'm in
100 yeah but that's like i gotta get
away got away yeah no and that's and
that's totally fair a lot of people who
have the same setup that we do
are doing the same thing
uh
and it's like it basically is like you
know the one wheel xr came out almost
three years ago it was announced like
over two and a half years ago
and in that time the the like
third-party manufacturers have gone and
released all the accessories you could
possibly have to basically replace all
the main components of the onewheel with
the exception of the controller and the
motor but the battery's been replaced
the framework has been replaced the the
plastic bumpers have been
replaced yeah um yeah
so you have the pintxr yeah i have the
pintx pintx pintx which is literally
just a pint with different bumpers on it
to give it a little bit more volume in
the in the
in the battery compartment so that they
can actually put a onewheel xr battery
inside of it
gotcha originally they had this whole
announcement last week talking about how
they have the performance of the xr
right yes including like the the torque
the power the speed more torque
technically because it's a
smaller diameter tire so just the
mechanical advantage of a shorter radius
the same amount of force what would you
say your pros and cons are right now in
the pinetex okay so pros and cons of the
pintx
uh starting off with a con i'm not a big
fan of the pint profile it's a smaller
one wheel it's a little bit more
squirrely
the foot pads are flat it's a little bit
more susceptible to
hitting random bumps and throwing you
but it is also very maneuverable it's
it's a perfect pint for like riding
around in our studio for instance it's
very nimble uh the biggest thing i
didn't like about the original pint was
that it didn't have a very high top
speed like the top speed was like 15
miles an hour so you would hit push back
at like 12 13 miles an hour push back is
where it's like you hit a certain speed
and then it just kind of orients the
board backwards like this so the nose is
pointing straight up and straight up
not straight at an angle it's pointing
upwards at an angle
[Laughter]
yeah and so that's to like you know
notify you that you're hitting the top
speed of the board don't go past this
because you can push through it you can
continue to lean forward and the board
will level back out again but now you're
at a point where you're in danger zone
if you lean forward it's just going to
nose dive on you and you know future
motions they've got like lawsuits and
stuff from people not noticing pushback
and so they're having to engineer all
these extra safety precautions so
there's a whole that's a whole other
thing about like the right to repair and
them just getting sued and it's a bunch
of stuff anyway
that's why i didn't like the pint is
because you'd get to a decent cruising
speed of just like you know 14 15 miles
an hour going down the street but your
nose would be up in the air you feel
like captain morgan with your knee up
just cruising along it's not it's very
uncomfortable
but the pint x
with the higher power they have it has a
higher top speed of 18 miles an hour so
you don't get pushed back until around
17 miles an hour so you can be cruising
at 15 without ever getting pushback so
it's already way better than the
original pint it goes
two to three times further
it goes faster it's way more comfortable
but i would prefer the xr one wheel over
the pintx because it's a bigger tire
bigger board to stand on it feels more
stable
but they did send it to me for free so i
cannot complain
that's a really good review it's a
really good review
yeah so i i i find myself for the
longest time i had like one one wheel
and it was my favorite thing and then i
got the xr and so i never used the one
the first one wheel again
and now in less than a year i'm very
quickly finding myself with numerous one
wheels and it's the best thing ever we
need to build a proper one-wheel parking
rack
in our studio oh oh oh oh
sorry i
i had an excellent idea over the weekend
for a project that is an automatic
storing stand and charging station for
one wheel you pull up to it it's this
framework that you basically uh it's
either
firm enough on the ground you pull up to
it and you like kind of skid stop into
it and automatically text it and these
detects that it got hit and so these
hooks pull up from the the underside of
the the handle
pulls it up against the wall and then
this robotic arm with the charge port on
it sticks in it
uh and charges it and then you just hit
a button and it pulls out and lowers it
down and you can get on it and right
away
i
gave a lot of this over the weekend
i feel like you and natalie would be all
over this
the only thing that would that concerns
me would be the uh the getting the
charge port aligned properly with the uh
it's tough one it takes some force and
jimmy to get it in there i was thinking
you might need like a little bit of a
camera with some like computer vision
stuff
if you have a different one wheel like
if you have the xr yeah it would it
would be very much so a
one-way model
you're gonna have to accommodate for
that based on like weight i think that's
a great idea but sooner than that we
could just at least get a nice rack with
like a lot of chargers so we could kind
of like
well
i've been around a lot of projects in
this park so you know it takes a while
so
i've been around a lot of projects here
let's do this run let's wait until we
get on this let's wait until we get one
of those brand integrations from like
google
you know where it's like i don't know
how we're going to make this work with
it with it with a video and then we'll
just it'll just be like
some random sponsor and they'll sponsor
the the whole build dude yes
yeah like i'm super down like they're
like hey we like your channel we want to
give you money to promote our thing but
we don't care what you do it's like oh
okay what ideas
[Laughter]
uh cnc or laser cut a bunch of like thin
aluminum panels that you would design
specifically to be bent into place
for the framework and stuff like that
and do you think we should get a cnc
cutter though yeah just just to have one
we've been
talking about that which which number do
you guys think is bigger the amount of
onewheels sold or the amount of
subscribers the quarter crew channel
oh quarter crew channel
i know how many onewheels have been sold
i mean it's a few hundred thousand huh
i don't know if you can say that you
might affect the markets
i'm not publicly traded never mind yeah
and i did not hear any of this from
future motions so okay so it's fine well
there you go
now future motion crew is pretty pretty
tight-lipped about stuff that they're
supposed to be tight-lipped about i've
tried
like for instance i received the pintx
like 30 minutes before the actual
announcement video dropped but i had no
idea what it was going to be i was asked
on sunday like hey what's a good mailing
address for something to arrive on
wednesday i was like oh cool like
they're going to see like an accessory
or something and then the next day they
announced that they're going to announce
something and that's when i was like
what's it gonna be what's it gonna be
yeah so i had no idea so they announced
two onewheels the gt is not out yet it's
gonna be shipping in january uh they
told me that they will send me one so i
will be getting a gt and i'm incredibly
excited about it okay well we can all
test them out before
we make uh crippling financial decisions
crippling liberating liberating
what you're looking for is liberating
liberating the money from the wallet yes
because i was absolutely going to buy
one like the moment i saw the gt i was
like
he was going to buy one we'll take
[Applause]
all right um yeah i guess so you got to
go nick it's uh
yeah we should probably
605.
some good ghost stories going on that
was exciting yeah it was it was
something i really was anticipating
now is here to listen to the story yeah
i was just here to listen
it was basically like all of you
listening right now
contributed nothing but damn was it fun
you were a great listener today matt and
i really appreciate the ramen jacket i
get a gold star and a nice ramen jacket
if you guys are looking to uh have a
an adventure through youtube check out
ghost town living though it's a really
fun journal yeah
if you want to watch like a long video
he's got a lot of those they're all like
an hour long
oh and uh so our video collabing with
him does come out on november 21st so
that's in like two or three weeks from
here my birthday is it really woo happy
birthday nico
it's not my birthday yet don't say that
is that sacrilege
david yeah
birthday come true
[Laughter]
like older
i don't know what it is i just know i'm
older now
all right jake you want to play us out
oh yeah give us a spooky song
give us a real song
[Music]
i heard one note
oh here sorry hold on
watch the sound suppression again
no pressure
[Music]
spooky that's spooky that's pretty
spooky
[Music]
we're walking down an abandoned mine oh
yeah
the bats
lots of spooky holes
yeah chris
3d scan in the back oh nice pretty sure
he's i don't know i don't think anyone
else has ever 3d scanned a bat before
that's sick another record broken
more records
how deep does that hole go
i guess we'll find out
number two
because
three two one